break-in has left a Fitness business in
Summerlin just relaying
to open
20 located on Hualapai and Flamingo
reporter Brian will joining us live with
what happened and why this equipment
Brian is so very unique
these doors behind me is where thieves
forced their way into this business as
you can see they're working on getting
the lock repaired right now the owners
here at body 20 are hoping someone knows
something about this
a 53-inch TV
um a speaker
our x-body machines instead of spending
four to five hours at the gym you spend
20 minutes with us twice a week and you
get amazing results Libby Anderson and
her husband have invested their time and
money into establishing this new Fitness
franchise but on Wednesday morning Libby
walked into body 20 to quite the
surprise I felt very violated I don't
you know it's just like what do you do
everything was taken and it's like just
kind of overwhelming 12 of the workout
suits valued at about five thousand
dollars each were gone a TV was missing
same with a laptop thieves even took
water bottles and t-shirts I can't
believe it that someone would come in
and take something that
and just yeah it's kind of frustrating
and disheartening I guess but we'll
figure it out they were just getting
ready to launch and had been offering
demos of their workout suits to the
public we're gonna open in May so we
were just giving everybody a taste of
what's to come and now we can't do that
even after this setback they're not
deterred we're still gonna do it so I
mean we started we're not finished we're
not like we're not quitting
right
and they are not quitting now what makes
these suits so special is that you put
them on and actually contract your
muscles which should lead to more a
shorter and intense workout live in
Summerlin Brian will eight news now and
the owners tell Brian the suits may be
hard to sell because they can't be used
due to them being the only ones to
unlock them for use